large testing and vaccinations expanded
out into bedford burnley hounslow
kertsley
leicester and north tyneside as well as
supporting the scottish government
taking similar action
in glasgow and moray and the health
secretary repeating really what he said
on monday saying that the race between
the virus and the vaccine
has got a whole lot closer but
just to caveat that with some slightly
more
encouraging news the prime minister was
quite positive
in the commons at pmq saying that the
early
data looked encouragement courage and
i've spoken to
a senior government figure this
afternoon that says in terms of
transmissibility
it is not perhaps as transmissible as
first
feared the engine variant and in terms
of the vaccine
effectiveness against it that's also
looking
positive so some encouraging signs in
terms of the data but where does it
leave ours
when it comes to unlocking completely on
june the 21st it's still
a wait and see one cabinet minister said
to me
we knew this would never be a linear
path out of lockdown that there would be
bumps
along the road i guess the question is
whether this
particular bump completely throws the
prime minister off course but as i said
the early signs on the data and i must
stress it's wait and see
but inside government there's some
relief and encouragement
uh about how this variant is behaving
uh and also how it's behaving when it
comes to the vaccine
hello beth nick croatia with us now on
the news hour
so uh holidays amber signals
uh that's surely going to be pressed on
that too
yeah i mean look the uh back and forth
on
holidays on travel on whether you should
go to an amber country
shouldn't you go the prime minister
trying to clear up what has
i can only say been mixed messages from
different ministers
uh over the past 24 hours lord bethel
actually in the house of lords a health
minister saying last night it's
dangerous
to travel no one should be traveling
abroad now you'll remember the
government guidance is actually
there are greenless amber and redless
countries a dozen
countries in the green category one
including
portugal which obviously is a popular
holiday destination
but other popular holiday destinations
in that amber category and the prime
minister very clear today he said you
should not be going on holiday
to ambulance countries you should only
travel there in extreme circumstances
say a relative is ill and you wanted to
go and visit them and he reiterated the
fact that if you did go
to an amber country when you come home
you must isolate for 10 days
failure to do so could lead to a 10 000
pound fine but with dozens and dozens of
planes flying out to amber list
countries criticisms
uh that the government are not being
stringent enough on the borders
and matt hancock will have
no many questions no doubt uh flanked by
a couple of
other uh health officials too
but you know we talk about boris johnson
there and
you mustn't go to an amber country
unless
it is really necessary maybe he should
tell some of his ministers that
well in terms of going to other
countries there is the ambulance there's
also the red list and i think one of the
things that will come up potentially in
this press conference is exactly what
matt hancock said about the india
uh red listing uh when was india red
listed
was that uh delayed unnecessarily why
was pakistan
and bangladesh put on the red list long
before
india was and we've seen the
repercussions
of that in terms of this now highly
transmissible
indian variant across the country and
nervousness about whether this would
throw the unlocking on june the 21st off
track so i think matt hancock will have
uh potentially a couple of questions on
that at the press conference but you're
right he's also going to be joined by
janice
jenny harris from nhs england and
professor jonathan van tam the deputy
medical chief medical officer and in
terms of those that
pair i imagine jonathan professor van
tam
will be talking about the variant about
transmissibility and
look to see what jenny harris says as
well about
hospitalizations because what is key in
all of this
is not just the transmissibility of the
virus but
actually hospitalization so i think the
health secretary is now there
good afternoon for today's coronavirus
briefing and i'm joined by deputy chief
medical officer
professor jonathan van tan and dr jenny
harris the chief executive of the uk
health security agency i'd like to
update you on what we're doing to fight
the virus
both at home and abroad first turning to
what's happening here in the uk i'll ask
professor van tan to set out the
numbers and the details in a moment but
overall hospitalizations and deaths
remain
very low meaning that we've been able
carefully
to take away more restrictions this week
as we've taken step
three of the roadmap but we must proceed
with vigilance and everyone taking
personal
responsibility we've always known
that one of the things that has the
potential to knock us
off track would be a new variant
that's why we made the presence of a new
variant that could do that one of our
four tests when we set out the road map
which is the test we must pass before
going down each step of the roadmap
the early evidence suggests that the
b1617.2
new variant first discovered in india
passes on more easily from person to
person than the b
117 variant that was first discovered of
course in kent
but as the prime minister said at
lunchtime we have increasing
confidence that the vaccines are
effective against it
that means that our strategy is the
right one
to carefully replace the restrictions on
freedom
with the protection from the vaccine
what it means is that it is even
more important that people get
vaccinated
as i've reported to the house of commons
there are now 2
900 cases
known of this variant in the uk and we
are determined to do
all that we can to ensure this new
variant doesn't put our recovery at risk
so we've acted fast to guard the gains
that we've made together
we now have an incredibly sensitive
biosecurity surveillance system here in
the uk
and i'm going to set out a couple of new
details about that in a moment
this surveillance system spotted the
cases in bolton
and in blackburn early and through
surge testing and increased vaccinations
we're throwing everything at it there
the weekly case rate in bolton
is now 283 per 100 000
and it's doubled in the last week there
are now
25 people in bolton hospital with kovid
the majority are unvaccinated nearly 90
percent
have not yet had two vaccines
this shows the importance of getting
vaccinated
not once but twice
so when you get the call get the jab
almost fourteen thousand vaccines have
been given in
blackburn and bolton since friday and
over twenty six thousand doses have been
given in the last week the highest
weekly total
in these areas we've also searched
testing and delivered 75 000 extra tests
to these two areas
and we're using 12 testing sites and 100
strong team going door to door but these
are not the only areas where we have a
cause for concern
we're seeing other cases where rates are
rising
and where we need to act fast as we have
in bolton and blackburn
we know that this playbook that we're
using in bolton and blackburn
worked in south london against the south
african variant where we had
a series of cases of the south african
variant
and we brought that under control and
we've used our extensive surveillance
system
and new techniques to identify the areas
we're most concerned about
we of course look at the number of cases
we look at the
number of identified variants and we
look at hospitalizations and we publish
all of these data
but we're now also able to use two
further
tools mobility data shows
travel patterns in different areas and
we look at this in deciding
where the virus is at risk of spreading
and next we also analyze wastewater in
70 percent of the country and we can
spot the virus
and the variants in the water and that
can help us identify
communities where there's spread as a
result of all this analysis we're now
surge testing
and increasing vaccinations in bedford
burnley leicester kirklees
north tyneside and hounslow in london
and we're also supporting the scottish
government who are taking similar action
in glasgow and murray
what this means in practice is putting
in more testing
more testing sites and on vaccinations
making more vaccinations available to
everyone
who's eligible and to everyone across
the whole country
i'd urge vigilance as we open up and of
course
as soon as you're able to to get the jab
so everyone in these areas please
exercise caution
get a test and as soon as you're
eligible get the jab
as we carefully replace this shield of
restrictions
with the sword of the vaccination
program to give us protection for the
long term
we keep driving the vaccination program
as fast as we can
i'm delighted to say that as of midnight
last night seven out of ten
adults in the uk have now had their
first dose
that's seven in ten people who have a
big degree of protection against the
virus
i'm also delighted that almost four in
ten
have had the extra protection that comes
from having two doses
and i'd like to show you a chart which
puts this into context
and shows this protection across the
country and also
to help explain why we've taken the
decision to change our dosing interval
from 12 to 8 weeks for the most
vulnerable
this chart shows the proportion of
people who've had the jab according to
age group
green bars represent people who've had
one dose blue bars represent people
who've had
two and as you can see from the amount
of green
uptake of the first dose has been
phenomenally
high and we followed the strategy of
getting first doses to as many
people who are vulnerable to covid as
possible as quickly as possible
and for that read the the over 50s in
particular
now you can see the very very high
uptake rates and we're incredibly proud
of how much people have stepped forward
but there's still a little bit of a gap
between the green
bars and the hundred percent and
what the experience of bolton shows is
it's incredibly important
that we get vaccination even to the
final few percent
and encourage that take-up and then
the blue bars show the second doses and
we can see that the uptake of the second
doses
has been incredibly high too
but again there's a little bit of green
showing and we need to get the blue bars
the
second doses up to everybody who's had
the first dose and of course the as you
go down the age range to the towards the
left of the chart
fewer people have had two doses because
it has been
less time since they had the first dose
this is why getting the second dose in
to those who are most vulnerable to
ending up in hospitalization
in the hospital and dying of the disease
is so
important academic studies have
shown that this decision to have 12
weeks between the first two doses
has saved around 12 000 lives
but that uptake those figures are not
yet a hundred percent and we will not
rest until we get them there
and crucially this acceleration now of
second doses for the
for the over 50s for the most vulnerable
is all about getting the maximum
possible protection
for those at greatest risk and while we
do
while we deliver on the first and the
second doses we're also working on our
booster program too and i just want to
update you a little on that
this is all making sure that the
vaccines
stay ahead of the virus this includes
new vaccines specifically targeted
at variants of concern i'm delighted to
be able to announce a new
clinical trial backed by 19 million
pounds of taxpayers money
to look at the use of current covid
vaccines as
booster vaccines and to see what
combination
and what part they can play in keeping
us safe for the long term
and you can sign up to be part of this
trial
on w www.covboost.org.uk
this will be the first clinical study in
the world
to look at the impact of a booster jab
and i'm very pleased that we're leading
the way with this scientific endeavor
just as we have done so many times in
this crisis
take for example the huge advances we've
made in genomic sequencing
today we've published our genome uk
implementation plan
for how we can build on this genomic
science even further
including our commitment to sequence one
million whole genomes
and i want to thank all the scientists
and all those at genomics england
who've been involved in delivering this
which is also through their genomic work
played such an important part in our
tackling uh the
pandemic genomics saves lives we learned
that
through this pandemic so clearly and
then determined that the uk
stays at the forefront of this
scientific endeavor as well
we're not just focused on the effort at
home so a few words about how we're
working to protect people
all around the world we've donated over
half a billion pounds to kovacs which
has now discovered
life-saving covert 19 delivered
life-saving coveted 19 vaccines in 120
countries and territories
but and i really want to stress this
point
over and above our cash commitment the
uk
has probably done more than any other
nation
to help vaccinate the world's poorest
and that's thanks to the gift to the
world of the oxford astrazeneca
vaccine which is available at cost
no charge for intellectual property
we invested the british government
oxford university
and astrazeneca the three of us we
invested
in the research and came together to
develop
and deliver this vaccine at cost
for everyone and for context
in terms of the scale of the impact of
what we've done here
almost 1.5 billion vaccine doses have
now been injected across the world
more than 400 million of them have been
the oxford astrazeneca vaccine
and in total the oxford astrazeneca
vaccine has been now delivered
in 160 countries two-thirds
of this 400 million doses two-thirds
have been
injected into the arms of people in low
and middle-income countries
including for instance 117 million in
india
where they've been obviously so badly
affected by this
virus and of the 67 million doses
delivered through kovacs over 65 million
of them
have been the oxford astrazeneca vaccine
this
vaccination program is a vaccination
program for the world
using the oxford astrazeneca vaccine
it's something
every british taxpayer has had a part in
supporting
and everyone in this united kingdom
should be incredibly proud of it
rather than changing the rules as we got
many jabs into arms right across the
world
we just got on with delivering this at
cost without any profit and i want to
thank the team at oxford
and astrazeneca for the incredibly
progressive and forward-looking
approach that they took over a year ago
now
to set this up and it is having an
impact everywhere
so just as we fight the virus at home
we'll stand side by side with other
nations across the world
and i just want to add one more thing
because if this pandemic has taught us
anything it's taught us that our health
is intertwined together
next month i'll be welcoming health
ministers from g7 nations to oxford
the birthplace of this vaccine that
saved so many lives
and there will hold the g7 health
ministers forum
not just to talk about how to fight this
pandemic in the here and now
but how we need to emerge stronger
healthier
and safer with the great democracies of
the world
working together this after all is a
virus
that attacks all of humanity and it
calls upon
everyone to step up and think about what
we can do and
you can play your part in that too in
the same way
that everybody has played their part so
far
so please remember the basics hands face
space
and fresh air and even as we take
this these steps together get your rapid
regular tests
and when you get the call get the jab
i'll now hand over to professor van tam
to go through the data thank you
secretary of state good afternoon
the slides today are quick simple and
thankfully
should contain no surprises to anyone
let's have the first slide here we go
this slide is the number of people
testing positive
for covid 19 in the uk you can see the
big
winter wave of january and february
and you can see now on the right of the
slide
that we are in a very low place indeed
the most recent seven day average is
just over two thousand
cases per day and that trend is
absolutely flat
next slide please
there's better news on the number of
people in hospital with covid19 in the
uk
better than flat again you can see that
massive peak
in january in february peaking at almost
40 000 people in hospital
we're now down on the 17th of may to
under a thousand people
in hospital with covert 19 939
and that's a drop of 1717
in the last week next slide please
in terms of the number of deaths of
people who've had a positive test
result for covid in the uk in the last
28 days
the most recent seven-day average is now
running at
eight deaths per day these are still
regrettable but we are nevertheless in
an extremely low place
compared with where we were back in
january and february
next slide please and finally this is a
different depiction of the data that
you've already seen in an animated form
from the secretary of state you can see
that we are now at almost
37 million individuals who've received
their
first dose of a covid19 vaccine in the
uk
and we are now at around about 20
million just over
for people having received both doses of
the vaccine
what is really important now is that we
close the gap
and turn that 20.9 million people who've
had their second dose
into 37 million people
who've had their second dose and that's
the challenge
of the next few weeks thank you
secretary steve
thank you very much professor van tan
we're now going to go to questions
from the public and then questions from
journalists and the first question from
the public by video
is helen from manchester helen
not including the autumn booster how
long do you anticipate vaccination
protection
will last and when will we need a
further booster
it's a great question helen i'm going to
hand over straight to jvt
thanks for the question helen
the short the short answer is is that we
don't yet know
we do have data now showing that
antibodies are persisting
for at least six months but antibodies
on their own and not the totality
of the protection you get from vaccines
you also get
important t related protection that is
more difficult
to measure we are we can't
make time go faster so we simply have to
watch
very vigilantly to make sure that we're
not starting to see
lots and lots of cases of covert 19
in people who've been fully vaccinated
that would be a telltale sign
that vaccine effectiveness is starting
to wane
and we just don't know it is perfectly
plausible
that in the absence of variance
then the vaccine protection particularly
in the younger adults
might last for quite some time but we
we're entrusting
our jcvi who've done such a good job so
far
to look at this they've already started
addressing this question
and we will step by step as the science
unfolds
keep an eye on this and then the jcbi
will make an advice to
advice to government about what the next
steps are
but on the vaccine procurement side
the vaccine task force is doing
everything it can
to keep as many options as possible open
so that the jcbi has got that choice of
strategy
according to when and where and what we
need
thanks very much professor next question
is from iris in london
given the increased risk of
complications for pregnant people
and the updated guidance recommend
vaccinations for those pregnant
why aren't pregnant people prioritized
over their age groups for the covet-19
vaccination
thank you iris it's a another important
question i'll ask
dr harris to answer that uh thank you
aries for that and um you'll probably
have noticed that the
guidance has been very cautionary uh
people uh women who were pregnant were
included in the um
advice for the clinically extremely
vulnerable at the start
um and the same precautionary approach
has been applied to
vaccination and professor van tan may
want to add to my comments in a moment
but i think what we have we didn't have
any information specific to
pregnant women at the start we have now
acquired that over time
and we think it is it's perfectly safe
for women to have that mixed with
pregnancy will be
women who have specific underlying
conditions so if you are a
pregnant woman with underlying
conditions then clearly you will be
treated within that
risk group but for pregnant women
otherwise who are otherwise
fit and healthy uh it's entirely
appropriate jcvi have looked at the
evidence
uh to be called in with your own age
group but
not not to receive the az vaccine
because most of the evidence
is for other vaccination types at the
time at this time
thank you very much anything grad
nothing to add thank you
thanks very much we'll now go to hugh
pim from the bbc hugh
thank you very much secretary of state
at what point do you think
you'll have enough data on the spread of
the indian variant and the impact on
hospital numbers
to give a clearer picture on the next
stage of the roadmap
and a question for you and your
colleagues what is your current
assessment of how fast this new variant
is spreading
relative to the existing uk variant
thanks very much hugh so i'll start i'll
answer the
uh part of the question and then pass on
to professor van tam to answer the rest
in terms of the road map we've set out
that we will take
step four not before the 21st of june
and we will give a decision on that on
the 14th of june
using all the information that we have
up until then
now clearly every day we're getting more
information
getting more information about how many
people are in hospital in the areas
where
there are hot spots of this new variant
and we're getting more scientific
information that um the professor can
take you through
so in terms of making those decisions
we'll look every day at the data
and we'll make a final decision on the
on on
whether we can go ahead with step four
and we'll make
and publish that decision on the uh on
the 14th of june
until then it is just too early to say
and uh all i can tell you is that we we
remain vigilant and
and this data on the number of cases and
the number of hospitalizations
is published and updated every day
professor
yep thank you all i can add really is
that
um i think scientists are sure that this
virus is more transmissible
than the strain that it is beginning to
replace which is the old
kent b 1.117 strain
the question and you know the million
dollar question is
how much more transmissible and we don't
have that yet
we have a credible range that goes from
a few percent
more transmissible through to and you've
probably read the sage papers
through to 50 percent more transmissible
i think most people feel it is going to
be
somewhere in the middle rather than at
the extremes of that
band but it is just too early
the best estimate i can give you really
is that the data will begin to firm up
sometime next week
and i think next week will be the first
time when we have a
ranging shot at what the
transmissibility increase
is and that will then feed into
models that will help us understand
how this looks in terms of the future
prospects in terms of
resurgent disease and
from there ministers will be able to
make
further decisions but what i can say in
the meantime
is that i pitch this personally
as a straight race between the
transmissibility
of this new variant
that transmission is not inevitable
people
can slow it down through cautious
behavior
they can slow it down through using test
trace and isolate and
that cautious behavior is very important
where we know
there are hot spots so on the one side
the race is transmissibility
the other competitor in the race is
vaccine delivery
and the nhs is doing everything it can
to turbo boost that and that is that is
the
challenge that's ahead of us in the next
two to three to four weeks to see
to make sure that we outrun the virus
through really vigorous pull through on
vaccine delivery
and that is why when you are called
you must come forwards and help us
finish the job
thanks very much hugh next question is
from emily morgan at itv
emily thank you very much um
you're hoping to stop the spread of the
variant uh with
vaccinations and surge testing but it is
still spreading so it appears that surge
testing
isn't actually working with millions of
people still not vaccinated
aren't you afraid that this will
inevitably lead to more hospitalizations
and deaths
well not necessarily is the answer and
that's why we've taken the approach
that we have because we saw surge
testing work effectively in
reducing the spread of the south african
variant
in south london and if you remember we
discussed this about
a month ago we put in a huge amount of
testing
about a quarter of a million tests were
taken in south london in a very short
space of time
and that did manage to stop the spread
of that
of that variant and and i'll ask jenny
harris to
explain the details of what we're doing
not just now in bolton and blackburn but
more broadly where there are hot spots
and but we have seen this playbook work
and we want to do that the advantage we
have now compared to say in the autumn
when the kent variant first arrived
is we just know so much more about it so
much faster because of this
extraordinary surveillance capability
so we could spot the rise in cases very
very early
and it means that we can act in this way
without having to make
take more drastic action given that the
overall picture when
when you take the nation as a whole uh
is uh is is
is really quite positive thank you
secretary so yes so
i think the original question was around
vaccination i would just like to
highlight
uh the point that's been made in the
really fast uh
moving of this this turbo charging to
the vaccination program
so just in bolton alone last weekend 6
000 people were vaccinated
for a small area i think this is down to
the really hard work of our nhs
colleagues
local authority director of public
health everybody working together to
ensure
people come forward for their second
dose if they haven't had their first one
to do that but in terms of what we're
doing as the secretary of state has said
we are in a completely different
place to where we were last year our
genomics testing
is is probably the best in the world
we're donating uh
30 to 40 percent of of giza tests so
we're showing the world what we're doing
uh and and actually giving other
countries information about the variants
which are arising
and with that very uh precise testing
we can follow uh backwards follow-up
chains of transmission
undertake very enhanced contact tracing
so people
are going uh using shoe leather to going
door-to-door
working in these areas to support
individuals
increase the testing capacity so for
example bringing testing
into schools again so that we're sure
that people are able to do the test
properly and support them to do that
and then supporting individuals with
isolation so
there are flexibilities about financial
support
in many areas to allow people who might
otherwise be worried about being able to
afford to isolate
to be able to stay out of circulation
and therefore
decrease the the transmission risk so i
think
um although there are a lot of cases we
actually have evidence so sefton for
example has done a brilliant job
recently
uh with the rising cases of the variant
of this variant
and actually that has now plateaued and
has started to come down again so
it is is not a game lost at all it's
very much one to fight and there are
huge resources
and huge amounts of effort uh
particularly from the public in all of
these areas and
we should continue to do that i mean i
just had
reflecting on on dr harry's answer and
your question i just had one thing which
is
you know this is on all of us
again you know we are masters of our
fate by
by taking the tests in one of these
areas by getting coming forward and
getting vaccinated
by behaving with caution and we all know
the things that we need to do
especially outside is safer than inside
and
wearing masks we can get this under
control
but again it is for something for us to
do
as a community and in particular in the
areas where we're seeing the faster rise
jvc i just want to add and pick up on
your comment that we're
hoping to stop the spread with vaccines
yes of course we are but on their own
they will need support from people being
cautious
and from the test trace and isolate i've
said it many times at this podium i've
said it to say
probably countless patients that i
vaccinated with the first dose
please remember it's going to take
probably around 21 days
for you to have some protection from
your first dose of vaccine
now thankfully with the second dose
we would expect that enhanced protection
from the second dose
to kick in much quicker but still with a
delay
and probably seven to ten days delay
and that helps explain why it's so
important now
that we push on and get as many second
doses
into people as possible
thanks very much indeed next question is
from kathy newman at channel 4 cathy
secretary of state you spoke about
standing side by side with other nations
in the world but tonight we're reporting
on the treasury's insistence that any
kovid related help
that your department gives to countries
like india
has to come out of the uk government's
overall
international aid budget would you like
the chancellor to reconsider that
well of course we're helping other
countries around the world including
india
and of course it counts as overseas
development aid because it
is but what i'm really pleased about is
that we've been able
to support india so much already we were
the first country to
uh to put in support and i've been
talking to my
indian opposite number and we we've
engaged on what they need
we've engaged for instance on the offer
of ppe
but they they have not asked for ppe
what they have asked for is
support with oxygen and so we've sent in
oxygen concentrators and machines that
that
that generate oxygen to be able to
support their
hospitals and we've been able to do that
within our within our aid budget and
working with our colleagues
right across the uk so we've been able
to
deliver support for india but as i said
in my opening remarks you know the
biggest thing that the uk has done
for the whole world including india is
by generating by developing and
deploying the
oxford astrazeneca vaccine at cost
it means that effectively we have
supported
the vaccination over over 400 million
people including over 170 million people
in india and so we can be very proud of
the part that we've played
in in tackling this around the world
harry cole at the sun budget
aren't you risking other international
aid projects sorry
harry was that you i'm sorry i was just
asking a quick follow-up if i made yeah
go ahead
think of oxygen generators out of the
overall
aid budget aren't you then risking cuts
to other international aid projects
oh no we have a very generous aid budget
overall 0.5 percent
of our gdp and
i think this is exactly the sort of
thing that we should be deploying in
terms of aid helping other countries
around the world
but obviously it is aid i mean that's
just by by definition if you send aid to
another country it's
uh it counts within the overseas
development assistance budget as it's
technically called thanks harry
thank you secretary of state um earlier
in the week ministers said that um
we could go to ambulance countries to
visit friends but today the prime
minister says we need an extreme reason
to go to an ambulance country can you
give us an example or two if possible of
what an extreme reason would be
and is it of regret to you that these
mixed messages have once again
dominated a week and are you going to
apologize to holidaymakers who once
again find themselves facing a summer of
chaos
when the list could have been explained
a little bit better uh
frankly and um a question forever
whoever can answer it really uh
whoever's best qualified to answer it um
the secretary of state mentioned that
there are 25 uh covered patients now in
bolton hospital
uh by my math that's up six uh from 19
last week is that rate of increase
uh a cause for concern or is it actually
better than feared
thanks very much i'll ask dr harris to
answer the second question on the first
question
we've been absolutely straightforward
about this and
i the thing is i think that the public
uh get it and understand
if you look at what the prime minister
said last week what i said at the
weekend what the
what i said in the house on monday what
the prime minister said at lunchtime
today
we've been absolutely crystal clear that
you should not go
to an amber or red list country on
holiday you should
only go in exceptional circumstances for
you're asked for examples an example
might be to visit a
a very ill family member
or to go to a funeral of somebody who is
very close to you
they're two reasonable examples and i
think
we have been really clear through this
pandemic
that there are some things that we have
banned in law
but there are some things that we do not
recommend but you don't necessarily have
to ban everything that
as a government minister if you don't if
you don't advise it and you think that
it
um isn't a uh the right thing to do you
don't necessarily
ban it there are many examples of that
but what we do know
is that the public have been brilliant
at exercising the personal
responsibility
that we are seeking and so i would
advise at all sun readers to listen to
the prime minister
to follow the government advice which is
on the government
website and to book a holiday if you
want a holiday abroad
that's what the green list is for or
like me to holiday at home jenny
thank you so on on the second question
about hospital numbers um
obviously it's not just bolton it's
every uh area where we're seeing
variants across the country we're
looking continuously to see if we are
getting increased uh hospital admissions
uh and and if there are any fatalities
for that sadly associated with it
um and as professor van tam has said
earlier
actually we we are not seeing that at
the moment and the change in numbers
that you've described is really too
small we're seeing a fairly flat level
of admissions we have cases and we
expect people to come in and out of
hospital
we're not seeing shark rises at the
moment but clearly we will
continue to monitor that the the only
other thing i would just add
as well is uh in interpreting some of
these numbers
uh we have continued to learn right
through the pandemic and the nhs now
offers pulse oximetry out to patients so
we might find that patients are in the
community more than they're in hospital
or vice versa
so i think we need to take an overall
consideration which is what we do on a
very regular basis
thanks very much any follow-ups harry i
can see you i can see you
yes please and with all due respect
secretary of state you haven't been
crystal clear have you because
on monday george eustis was saying that
it was okay to visit friends
in ambulance countries he was wrong
wasn't he that you the example you've
given isn't to visit friends it's to
visit very sick relatives
why why are these mixed messages well i
thought this subject might come up so i
took the trouble to look at what uh we
said when we
uh announced the travel policy ahead of
the
17th of may uh what the transport
secretary said to look at what the prime
minister said last week to look at what
look back at what i said at the weekend
to check the record of what i said in
the house on
on monday and to look at what the prime
minister said at lunchtime today
in order to in case this question came
up and um
you'll be uh glad to know that all of
those statements were
completely consistent and consistent
with the advice on the gov dot uk
website and that is that if you go to an
amber list
country when you come back you have to
go through the testing regime
with three tests you have to quarantine
and i can tell you that we have in the
last week done 30
000 home visits to check that people are
quarantining
and you should only go to a red list
country or an ambulance country
if you have exceptional circumstances
the purpose of the green list is that
we've looked around the world at the
countries where we think
that it is safe to travel both from a
point of view of having
no all very very low variance of concern
and a low case rate just as we have here
in the uk
that green list is there for people who
want to have you know
foreign travel and for instance for a
holiday the amber list
is not for holidays and the red list is
not for holidays
either that's the policy we've been very
clear and consistent in terms of
the language that the prime minister and
the transport secretary and i have used
and it's all been on the gov dot uk
website and i'm sure
that sun readers have got that from the
start
because we've also seen actually um
a we've seen the public
get it and many many members of the
public i know are looking forward to an
extremely good holiday in the uk this
summer
thanks harry next question is from
heather stewart at the guardian
hello secretary of state um the indian
variant appears to have been able to
take hold and spread rapidly despite
two-thirds of adults having received at
least one dose of the vaccine
given the concerns about other variants
emerging would it be prudent to wait
until all adults have at least some
protection before removing what you
called the shield of restrictions such
as masks
and distancing rules rather than
sticking to the 21st of june date in the
road map
and just for professor van tam you
talked about cautious behavior being
very important in those new hot spots
leicester and bedford and so on
i wonder whether you'd advise people
from take against taking advantage of
some of the new freedoms they've been
allowed this week such as meeting up in
in pubs and restaurants and and would it
be unwise for people from outside to
travel to these areas to visit family
and friends
thanks very much uh heather two
excellent questions i will
um all i'll say before handing over to
professor vantam on the roadmap is
you know we'll set out a decision on the
14th of june looking at all this
and all this data um you know we are
seeing the
vast majority of cases uh both of the
existing variant and of the b1 617.2
variant amongst
younger groups and unvaccinated people
you know
on the one hand that is actually a good
sign because it implies that
the vaccine is working effectively but
obviously we don't want to see a huge
increase in the number of cases
anywhere we have said all along that we
expect some increase
in cases and of course younger people
who are
much more much more likely to be those
yet to be vaccinated
um are uh are much less affected in
terms of hospitalizations
uh and deaths and that that core
uh fact about this virus underpins
the strategy and the roadmap that we've
set out jbt
yes thanks very much for the question uh
look
the areas that have been mentioned today
in the press briefing including bolton
are absolutely areas of concern
for now and i would advise the residents
in those areas
to think very carefully about the
freedoms they have
weigh up the risks and be very cautious
so if it is possible to do something
outside
better to do it outside it is if it is
possible to do something
with smaller numbers with people you
know
rather than multiple new contacts it's
better to do that
take it steady i think i've
said don't tear the pants out of it once
before from
this or a similar podium but frankly
we're back to that again now
the government has given people freedoms
to start to make these judgments
for themselves and i understand that you
know we can't live
for years and years on end with rules
you know people will have to learn to
manage these risks from covid
for themselves because this is not going
to go away
in the short term the medium term and
probably the long term
but you have to be cautious you have to
weigh it up
really carefully and if you don't feel
well
you need to absolutely get a test if
you're offered a test as part of the
surge testing
you need to have it you need to follow
the rules on isolation
and when you get the call for the
vaccine whether it's your first dose or
your second
remember this is a race against the
transmissibility of the virus
don't delay take up the offer come
forwards immediately
thanks very much indeed is that okay
heather
very good uh final question is from andy
woodcock at the independent andy
secretary of state's um the european
council has decided today that's going
to recommend to anyone who has been
fully and properly vaccinated can come
to the eu this summer
um there'll be a lot of people in the uk
who've had their two jabs they'll think
i've been vaccinated i'm safe i can now
travel to the eu
i can go to france or spain but i can't
come back
because if i do then i'll have to go
into quarantine as things stand
why is it that um people have been
properly vaccinated
aren't exempted from the traffic light
system and if i could ask the uh the
medical experts
if somebody has been fully vaccinated
what sort of risk do they actually
present
to um people if they go abroad um
it is the uh the decision by the
european union to allow vaccinated
people in a rational
decision to take at this stage thanks
very much andy
well the thing is that most areas of
europe most countries in europe have a
higher rate of
of the virus than we do some
significantly
and there is also a much more
significant presence of the
south african so-called south african
variant of concern
in mainland europe and
that's why we've chosen to put only
portugal out of mainland europe on the
green list and for instance
on the latest data the the proportion of
the south african variant
in france was around five percent and
hence we've kept it on the
amber list we take these decisions in
order to protect the recovery
at home and so of course the ma it's a
matter for the eu what their
international
travel rules are and largely it's a
matter for individual countries within
the
eu i've seen the proposals then it's not
a final decision i understand i've seen
the proposals from
the eu and obviously i talk to my eu
counterparts
uh all the time so we will work with
them
in the long term we need to find a way
to have safe
international travel but right now with
our levels of vaccination
really good but not yet there
we are i think wise to take a cautious
approach to international travel
um anything to add yes thanks for the
question it is a good question
vaccine effectiveness is not a hundred
percent
we know that from the clinical trials
and
we know that vaccine protection is going
to vary
by individuals it's probably going to
vary
by age there are some data that suggests
that protection is not quite as good
in people who have a suppressed immune
system
and it is possible that we will see some
signals in the future
that vaccines don't work quite as well
in people who have a range
of chronic illnesses so in other words
it's very personalized
how well the vaccine is going to work
for you
personally on top of that we can't solve
this by just measuring your antibodies
because t cell immunity is
far less measurable and is much more
difficult
to do and that's another component of
the
degree of protection you're going to get
and then
i think we can be very clear that
when or if a vaccine fails to give you
the maximum amount of protection that
you were hoping for
and what it says on the tin as it were
then
the things that are going to go first
are the vaccines ability
to protect you from infection
and to stop you from transmitting it to
others
the things that will go last are the
vaccines ability to stop you getting
into hospital having severe disease
and dying they're the bits that we think
you know are generally the strongest
even even with a a weaker vaccine
so from that perspective um
the bit that fails first if a vaccine is
not you know
100 is its ability to stop you getting
infection
and transmitting to others even if it
would still keep you out of hospital
and stop you from dying of covid so
that's a tricky nuance in terms of the
argument that just because you've had
vaccines
it's entirely safe to go abroad
everything is relative
and the other bit of relativity is
whether you're
when you go abroad jumping into a pond
with one shark in it
or jumping into a pond with a hundred
sharks in it it changes the likelihood
that you're going to get bitten
and the disease levels in these
different countries that are potential
destinations
are all very different and as we've just
laid out
some of them still have quite high
levels of disease activity
compared to the uk so i think it's a
fair ambition
i think it's a good aspiration but i
think we have to move very cautiously
and find our way forwards carefully on
this well there you are
professor vantam's theory of relativity
um uh
anything to add dr harris yes to say
that um the variant that we're looking
at now the b
uh 161 7.2 we think uh has been detected
in 48 countries today 44
of those uh confirmed on on gizaid which
is the the
international library if you like and it
just goes to show how many different
variants are out there and we've just
had a conversation about understanding
the vaccine effectiveness against that
variant and waiting for the information
so i think we still have a lot to learn
uh but as as professor van tam said a
good a good aspiration ambition
thanks very much indeed that concludes
today's coronavirus briefing from here
in downing street thank you
the health secretary there matt hancock
rounding off
today's downing street conference let's
get some instant analysis dr mike
tilsley's associate professor of
infectious disease modeling
at the university of warwick and also an
expert advisor to the government's
sage group hello there thanks for your
time this evening some instant reaction
so jonathan van tan there
said the data on this indian variant
will begin to firm up really firm up
next week
giving the first evidence of a
transmissibility
shot we already know that it's going to
pass on more easily than the kent
variant so is that a reasonable time
scale that
some further assessments could be made
in the coming days